Wie ist die Lage?
Sehr gut. Mein Neues Album "Spark" kommt gerade raus und ich bin sehr gespannt, wie es laufen wird.
Aber du hattest eine Pause bevor du das Album rausgebracht hast?
Warum?
Einige Kuenstler bringen jedes Jahr ein neues Album raus.
Ich weiss. Der Erfolg mit "If a song could get me you" war wirklich ueberwaeltigend.
Ich wurde eingeladen eine Tour durch Deutschland, Oesterreich und die Schweiz zu machen.
Und ich liebe das, weshalb ich es des Oefteren wiederholt habe.
Aber dann wollte ich auch ein neues Album machen. Ein drittes Album.
Ich hab die ganze Zeit daran gedacht, dass ich wieder schreiben muss.
Und dafuer brauchte ich Zeit. Ich schreibe all meine Songs selbst. Also hatte ich nach dieser langen Tour eine 7-monatige Pause in NYC.
Warum gerade NYC?
Warum nicht irgendwoanders auf der Welt?
Ich glaube es hoert sich ein wenig widerspruechlich an, dass ich nach NYC gegangen bin, um meine Ruhe zu finden für die Musik.
Eine chaotische Stadt, sehr laut.
Aber.. Vor allem ging ich dorthin, um mich zu isolieren. Um für mich zu sein.
Ich habe ein paar Freunde dort, aber nicht sehr viele.
Und wenn ich nach Oslo gehe..
Du musst wissen, wenn ich unterwegs bin, vermisse ich meine Leute sehr.. meine Familie, meine Freunde.
Wenn ich also nach Hause gehe bin ich immer in Gesellschaft, wie auch waehrend einer Tour.
Und wenn ich das bin, dann schreibe ich nicht.
So ist es halt.
Also ging ich nach NYC und ich konnte nicht sagen, wie lange es dauern wuerde. Und dann lief es darauf hinaus, dass ich 7 Monate da war.
Und ich denke der Kontrast und die Kraft,
die sich zwischen dem Laerm und der Verrücktheit dieser Stadt aufgetan hat, lässt jeden Tag anders aussehen.
Das von einem ruhigen Apartment zu betrachten, nur mit meinen Instrumenten um mich rum
brachte mir Tage, die ich einfach nur zum Schreiben nutzen konnte.
Dein Album hoert sich überhaupt nicht nach NYC an. Ich hoere keine Toene und Melodien raus, die an NYC erinnern.
Was denkst du, wie sich NYC anhoert?
Dein Album klingt mehr wie eine Landschaft, nach Entspannung und schoenen Gefühlen.
Er ist wirklich gut und gefaellt mir sehr!
Ich habe es einige Male in meinem Auto angehoert.
Es laeuft gut beim Auto fahren oder?
Die meiste Musik ist im Auto am Besten.
Ich liebe es, im Auto Musik zu hoeren.
Es ist schoen die Zeit zu haben, ein Album komplett anzuhoeren. Von vorne bis hinten.
Gab es einen Moment, wo du gedacht hast, NYC ist keine gute Idee? Oder wusstest du die ganze Zeit, dass es richtig war?
Nun ja, ich habe es geliebt dort zu schreiben und dass meine Tage sich nur darum gedreht haben, wann ich schreibe und nicht ob ich an dem Tag Zeit habe zu schreiben.
Zudem habe ich wundervolle neue Freunde gefunden. Ich hab viele Bands gehört, die nie in Norwegen spielen, hab viel neue Musik entdeckt.
Ich hab jeden Tag Englisch gesprochen und fing an hin und wieder auf Englisch zu denken und zu traeumen.
Das ist ein natuerlicherer Ansatz, um in einer Sprache zu schreiben, die nicht die Muttersprache ist.
Was mir nicht an NYC gefiel ist, dass es so weit weg ist von Oslo.
Ich bin jetzt 200 Tage im Jahr unterwegs, das ist fantastisch.
Und Skype hat definitiv mein Tour-Leben revolutioniert.
Das macht es einfacher, da man sich zumindest auf dem Bildschirm sehen kann.
Aber es war ein wenig hart, sich davon zu überzeugen, die richtige Entscheidung getroffen zu haben. Dass es wichtig genug war.
Aber ein Songwriter zu sein ist so ein großer Teil von mir.
Ich werde sehr ruhelos, wenn ich ueber einen gewissen Zeitraum nichts mehr geschrieben hab.
Es war wichtig das wieder geradezubiegen.
Und danach bin ich zurück nach Oslo gegangen.
Ich war umgeben von geliebten Personen und bekam ne Zeit lang..
nun ja, familiaere und freundschaftliche Liebe.
Ist das eine Belohnung für die Monate in NYC? Deine Freunde weiterzusehen? Deine Familie?
Zurück nach Oslo zu kommen fühlt sich immer wie eine Belohnung an. Ich vermisse es staendig, die Stadt und die Leute.
Die Straße in der ich lebe ist sehr belebt.
Ich kann dort entlang gehen und sehe etwa zehn bekannte Gesichter.
Das mag ich daran, in einer kleinen Stadt zu leben.
Was du jetzt machst ist deine zweite Karriere, wenn ich recht informiert bin.
Ja, das kann man so sagen.
Du hattest bereits vorher eine musikalische Karriere, aber es war eine komplett andere Musikrichtung.
Es war auch Popmusik. Es war die Art von Popmusik, die ich mit meiner besten Freundin geschrieben hab.
Im Pokémon Soundtrack!
Oh, wir waren nicht gluecklich darueber!
Wir waren 15 und 16 als wir den Plattenvertrag bekommen hatten, in Amerika.
Zwei norwegische Maedchen, das war sehr aufregend.
Wir haben unser Album aufgenommen und wir haben viele Songs mit fantastischen Pop Songwritern geschrieben.
Gerade als unser Album rauskommen sollte,
hat sich diese Moeglichkeit ergeben, einen Song auf dem Pokémon Soundtrack zu haben.
Und jetzt im Nachhinein sehe ich, dass das eine unglaubliche Chance war, die sich uns da eroeffnet hat.
Und die Single erreichte Goldstatus!
00:06:53.50,00:06:00.00
Es verkaufte sich etwa 500.000 Mal. Es war eine andere Zeit, aber es war wahnsinnig.
Aber du kannst es dir sicher vorstellen, wir waren 16 und 17 als es rauskam und hatten einen Song auf dem Pokémon Soundtrack.
Es war nicht cool!
Aber ich denke es hat uns die Tueren zu vielen neuen Zuhören geoeffnet.
Also war es gut.
Ist es schwierig, seine Karriere so zu aendern und sich zu entscheiden, die bisherige Musik nicht mehr zu machen.
und eine komplett neue musikalische Richtung einzuschlagen?
Nein, ist es nicht.
Ich denke wirklich nicht, dass es so ist.
Solange du die kreative Kontrolle hast, kannst du tun, was auch immer du willst.
Ich denke die Zeit in dem Duo war klasse für den Anfang.
Man hat jemanden um die Arbeit zu teilen, das Reisen, die neuen Erfahrungen, den Druck und auch all die kleinen Erfolge.
Du hast jemandem, mit dem du es wirklich feiern kannst.
Es war sehr gut, in der Zeit zu zweit zu sein.
Und diese 4 Jahre sind unbezahlbar!
Ich wuerde sie für nichts in der Welt hergeben.
Aber dann ging ich zurück nach Oslo und hatte ein paar Jahre, um die Dinge nachzuholen, die ich in der Zeit verpasst hab.
Ich musste zu Konzerten gehen, Wein trinken, unter gebrochenem Herzen leiden.. all diese Dinge, die man als Teenager durchlebt, aber nicht moeglich waren, als wir auf Tour waren.
Das habe ich wirklich genossen.
Und viel Musik kommt gerade aus den Zeiten. in denen man nicht danach strebt, welche zu machen. Für ein Album, an dessen Erscheinung man gebunden ist.
Ich hatte keine Vorstellung davon, ob ich überhaupt Zuhoerer haben wuerde.
Ich schrieb Musik, weil ich es wollte. Wie es sich ja natuerlich auch gehoert.
Und irgendwann hab ich dann gemerkt: Ich muss diese Musik teilen.
Ich bin nicht nicht durch mit dem Musikbusiness, ich versuche es erneut.
Ich muss Zuhoerer für diese Musik finden, so dass ich wieder auf Tour gehen kann, dass ich wieder aufsteige.
Und das tat ich!
Mit allem, was ich gelernt hatte, ist es nun eine tolle Erfahrung geworden, eine Solo-Kuenstlerin zu sein.
Ich hab damals einige Fehler gemacht, die ich dafuer jetzt nicht mehr machen muss.
Die Pause zwischen den beiden Karrieren war sehr wichtig?
Ich denke das war sie.
Um die Jugend zu haben?
Definitiv.
Denn als sich die Chance ergeben hatte, Musik in.. ich glaube 22 Ländern zu veroeffentlichen.. es war der Wahnsinn,
war es ein großes Abenteuer und zu so etwas kann man nicht nein sagen. Und es war fantastisch.
Aber ich denke, dass sich meine Perspektive durch die Pause veraendert hat, weil ich eine Zeit lang von allem entfernt war.
Und noch war es auf einem Level, dass ich wusste, wenn ich aufhoeren will kann ich aufhoeren.
Denn es ist ein verruecktes Leben.
Ich muss viele Opfer bringen. Ich bin entfernt von geliebten Menschen.
Ich reise zwar, aber auf einer Art, die nicht sonderlich interessant ist.
Ich reise von A nach B und dann habe ich Interviews, bin im Hotel
und gebe naechtliche Konzerte, was ich liebe! Und das ist es, worauf ich hinaus will.
Eine der wertvollsten Dinge, die ich gelernt habe, ist dass man wirklich für diese musikalischen Momente leben muss.
ich mache jeden Tag Musik, was mir bei Weitem das Liebste ist auf der Welt.
Und darum ist es mir die Opfer wert.
Also ist es sehr wichtig, nicht zu beruehmt zu sein und Pausen zu machen?
Ich denke so kann man es sagen.
Ich denke dabei an Justin Bieber. Er hat keine Chance auf eine Pause oder weniger bekannt zu sein.
Ich weiss. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, wie es sein muss, Justin Bieber zu sein.
Aber du willst es auch nicht?
Ja, es ist zu viel.
Und im Moment bin ich einfach so gluecklich mit meinem Leben.
Ich reise umher, sehe fantastische Orte und hab die Moeglichkeit vor einem Publikum zu spielen, das mich will wie ich bin.
Ich bin kein kleiner Part von etwas Groeßerem.
Natuerlich ist auch Justin Bieber nicht solch ein Part, das will ich damit nicht sagen, aber ich bin nicht  solch eine Art von Beruehmtheit.
Und wenn ich mal freie Zeit habe, kann ich einfach tun, was ich will
und ich hab das Glueck, eine Plattenfirma zu haben, die mich so sehr unterstuetzt, dass sie mich schreiben lassen so lange ich will und bis ich bereit bin, ein neues Album zu veroeffentlichen.
Ich denke, das ist sehr selten.
Ich bin sehr dankbar dafür.
Ich habe Freunde, die nicht solch ein Glueck haben.
Mich hat niemand angerufen und nachgehakt.
"Wo ist mein Album?"
"Schreibst du gerade Hit-Songs?"
Ich hab keinen solchen Druck.